thank you
our next guest Sal palantonio covering
his 30th Super Bowl 28th for the
mothership you can catch him on NFL
matchup show with Greg Cosell and Darius
Butler on Super Bowl Sunday 9 Eastern on
ESPN2 ESPN national correspondent
covering the NFL South palantonio
joining us on the program
looking good looking lean Looking ready
for Super Bowl Sunday
looks like he's ready for it a TV
appearance there you look like you're
ready for ready to go on TV you know as
a reporter you always have to be ready
whenever you would sit around the
mothership and that would be breaking
news then if you know depending on what
the sport was you go hey put on a jacket
I'm gonna prop you up and all of a
sudden you go on TV sound good to see
you grant great to be here Dan yeah
you're looking good I'm all right is it
different with your hometown team
yes just telling Todd you know I'm up to
my chest and snakes and alligators man
why and and that's everything all the
time it's 24 7 coverage you know as it
is when you covering a Super Bowl team
for ESPN but then you add the fact that
it's your hometown team
and uh there are a lot of requests a lot
and you know
you don't want anything to fall through
the cracks you don't want anything
anybody reporting a story before you do
either but how taxing is that for NFL
reporters certainly the importance of
the sport for ESPN of not it's not
taxing you know it's it's fun it's
definitely fun but if somebody beats you
to a story that you should have gotten I
blame it on Adam schefter
all else fails yeah you blame Chef you
could take him couldn't you
in in what way like a fight
probably I don't know
I've seen them I've seen him without a
shirt off Adam's got us he was in the
gym yesterday with me he's
he looks like he's doing pretty good
yeah but clear something up were you a
Navy SEAL I was not a Navy SEAL no I was
I was a surface Warfare officer in the
United States Navy for six years okay
but that sounds serious I went through
boot camp and officer candidate school
pretty rigorous training then you train
while you're in the Navy so what did you
want to do
excuse me what did you want to do in the
military
what did I I did my service I was in I I
enjoyed it it was great but I missed
so you have to make a choice really if
you're in the Navy you're either going
to be out at sea or you're going to come
home and and shefty hasn't been on a
destroyer
no
[Laughter]
telling you Mom I'd take you over
chefton those there was almost going to
be a fight in Houston almost at the bar
and I remember Sal pal was there and you
had my back
we won't talk about that
but but you know I we could talk about
it Michelle doesn't have to all I know
is there was a guy who wanted me to do a
shot and I didn't want to do the shot
wasn't Dibble there yeah I did so I do
remember it and all I know is I do
remember it quite well this guy was
getting in my face because I he said he
thought that I was too good to have a
shot with him and I'm going no I just I
don't want to do a drink if I do a shot
then somebody's going to say I saw him
do five shots
and all of a sudden
Sal is just staring at this guy and you
got your hands out
I don't know if you you recall what you
did but you're like ready to go
and you did have my nobody else who was
with me had my back but you did and you
were ready to maybe disarm this person
hey hey Dan sometimes sometimes you just
gotta look at a guy
and they know they got no shot okay all
right uh what is what is change so this
is your 30th Super Bowl yeah what's the
biggest change
social media yeah yeah gambling
big
you know this is the best Eagles team of
all time in my opinion
cover the team for 30 years but it's
also the most engaged team of all time
you know you go around Philadelphia yeah
30 000 people out on the streets when
they won the NFC championship game
people are totally emotionally engaged
in this team and I think a lot of it has
to do with gambling I really do people
are gambling on the NFL like crazy but
16 billion is going to be gambled on on
the Super Bowl 16 billion have they
broken it down by cities like where
Philadelphia would rank gambling on
Sundays Any Sunday top three you think
so sure you know when New York made
online gambling legal which was in
January of uh of this year excuse me
2022. we saw an explosion in gambling
when online gambling was legal in New
York and it's New York New Jersey
Pennsylvania that's that's the vortex
other than Las Vegas
How concerned are you of where we are
now to where we're going to be gambling
and you got to start thinking about
things that could go wrong nefarious
things I would think with the sport with
gambling I'm not too concerned about it
I'll tell you why I think there's enough
money in the sport you know if you're
talking about players and your coaches
right I think there's enough money in
the sport where
99.9 of those involved in the sport are
not
in Jeopardy of saying okay I got to do
something they won't be tempted by it it
won't be tempted it's not the Temptation
there and the league has put in
great safeguards I think and protections
and they scare the players and the
coaches enough that this is this is
something you can't do Sal palantonio
the mothership joining us here in uh
Scottsdale Stadium not a bad setup here
they gave us the ballpark last time I
was here I think I was having a beverage
of choice with Chris Berman
right like literally right on this spot
there's I think this is like a
Hospitality yes it is and yeah we've
come here a lot actually it's fun it's
fun you know I love baseball of it where
is the uh drama this week
oh man I think the number one drama has
to be is Jalen hurts fully healthy to
play the game absolutely and what are
you hearing I well I think he's healthy
enough to do what they need him to do to
win the game so
I was talking one-on-one with Shane
steichen yesterday no cameras you know
they have the coaching player
availability
and he was sitting at a table by himself
the offensive coordinated Eagles
no one was around him so I just pulled
up a chair next to him and the last
question I asked him I went through a
bunch of stuff and I just said to him
yes or no answer yes or no answer
will you be restricted in any way and
how you call the game based on Jalen
hurts his shoulder he said no
we're we're trying to win this game
we're going to go out and Win It
you think he's going to need surgery in
the off season no okay I don't because
it feels like we keep focusing on
mahomes's shoulder surgery is tough to
do anyway right yes yeah it's the only
way you really repair it is through rest
you know over the long period of time so
and he hasn't had that he has to had to
go back onto the field
the the high ankle sprain though
everybody wants to talk about that
because it's Mahomes yep Mahomes is
value to the Chiefs is different than
Jalen hurts 100 Eagles and what you're
going to ask them to do can the Eagles
get into a shootout
they don't have to and I don't think
that they will
they Rush 44 times against the Niners in
the NFC Championship Game
and you look at Mahomes he's ten and
three in the postseason ten and three am
I right about that Paulie ten and three
so you look at the three losses the
common denominator and the three losses
is he loses the time of possession yeah
right you got to play keep away from
Patrick Mahomes if you try to get into a
shootout you're going to lose
you got to play keep away the way to
play keep away is to run the football
Cincinnati had 18 rushes then 18 rushes
in the AFC Championship game you got to
run the football I know I sound like
some you know
dinosaur but in this game you gotta run
and play keep you put if you put Mahomes
back on the field you can't get them off
he's got a great third down completion
percentage they're great as a team on
third down they're great as a team on
fourth down
don't put the ball in his hands play
keep away because once you put him on
the field he's hard to get off the field
yeah I've said this before that these
games come down to can you make a stop
can you run the football and I want when
Mahomes gets on the field that now he
has to have a little more pressure to
make something happen because if he goes
off the field the Eagles run the clock
now you now you've reduced the number of
times he's going to get the ball now you
put a little more pressure on it number
one outlier in this game is the Eagles
offensive line
they are the best unit single unit in
this game without a doubt and they can
dominate yeah and they have and I think
that they will try to run the ball and
play keep away with Pastor McCombs you
know defense wins championships but
quarterbacks win the Super Bowl and
that's what you got to do you got to
prevent Patrick Mahomes from winning the
Super Bowl because in the fourth quarter
like you said you got to make a stop
he's hard to stop so if he's got the
ball in his hands with a chance to win
the game in the fourth quarter you're
probably going to lose he's probably
going to win is he a top 10 quarterback
of all time right now I don't think so
not yet not enough not enough time yet
Dan not enough time I don't think top
ten
you know he's getting there though he's
pretty darn good Dan orlovsky says that
Joe Montana is not a top five
quarterback Joe Montana is the number
one quarterback of all time ahead of Tom
Brady I agree with Lawrence Taylor I
take Montana over Brady why
so accurate
uh never lost a Super Bowl never through
an interception in a Super Bowl
just so intuitive with the ball and
don't forget you can't touch the
quarterbacks now right Montana used to
get hit oh gosh brutalize this all the
time and he hung in there I would take
Montana Brady is a close second but I
like Joe but if you look back and and
having you know covered the NFL and been
around for Elway in Montana those guys
weren't throwing 30 touchdowns in a
season because you know they the
offenses weren't they weren't geared
towards that or the defenses were a
whole lot better and More Physical you
know when people go you know Elway I
think through 30 touchdown passes maybe
once maybe Montana did it once as well
but that's not what their games were
predicated on Terry Bradshaw and the
Steelers weren't predicated on that yeah
you know we get caught up in what are
the numbers but if it came down to one
game it's like somebody said to me hey I
know you think LeBron's the greatest
basketball player of all time who would
you take into one game and I go I'd take
Michael sure but if I said um hey you
got one World Series game to win am I
picking Kurt Schilling sure John Smoltz
sure Jack Morris sure Tom Seaver they're
not the greatest pitchers of all time
that I'm taking so one game yes but
that's different you know Clayton
Kershaw has got a Hall of Fame career
but am I taking him over Kurt Schilling
the answer is no so I don't know what we
proved there
it was a good discussion Dan thank you
very much yeah appreciate it um the
commissioner said the officiating's
never been better
what did you make of that perfect never
been better yeah you know I think he's
got stats to prove it but I think you
know it doesn't pass the eye test for
most people but there's more social
commentary that's why I think there's
more debate that's and there's more
rules yep and that makes it tougher like
I give them the benefit of the doubt
because we've stood on the sidelines and
watched an NFL game it's hard to
officiate an NFL game it really is hard
and so much of it is subjective yes for
sure offensive holding I think is
subjective for sure defensive holding is
not I think and
I think roughing the passer is not
subjective it is not it really isn't so
there were times in that AFC
Championship game that I thought the
Chiefs should have been called for
roughing the passer on Joe burrow
several times yes yeah and certainly one
time there was several times yeah yeah
but they should review they should be
able to review roughing the passer yes
yep I agree with Belichick I think
pretty much everything should be
reviewable and Dan
put it on TV
why don't we put it on television I mean
when he go goes under the blue tent
start the cameras rolling live have Troy
Vincent join with audio audio the whole
smear put it all on TV well hey if we
can have if we can have cameras and
audio in a courtroom in the United
States of America why can't we have
football is more important than
courtroom I mean football's not more
important than a courtroom I mean we
broadcast
trials live why can't we broadcast a
review live and guess what you can
sponsor it you can make money off it
it'd be great
oh I love it and guess what else you
could do on it you know
Gamble
uh well you know we're going to get to
that you're going to be gambling on each
play
they do that now anyway in stadium
that's one of the biggest things you can
gamble
uh I and it's unbelievable how many how
much young people are gambling all the
time but getting back to the the
refereeing I think overall
they do as good a job as they can
and I think they can do better for sure
I think all you have to do is look at
the officiating Crews if you ever read
Kevin seifert's column on espn.com he
does an unbelievable job of reviewing
each crew
there's too much variation between the
crews on what they call
that shouldn't be happening but they
also shouldn't have All-Star Crews for
playoff games it should be the team that
you had I would agree with that because
I still go back to the Saints Rams game
if you had a team together egos wouldn't
have played a role there and and no
those guys would have huddled up and
said look you missed it we're gonna
we're gonna help you out on that and it
felt like
that it seems counter-intuitive that
they don't work together all year long
and then they're put together during the
biggest game on the planet
on one day they should be working you
wouldn't take a team of All-Stars and
put them in the Super Bowl you have to
you know work up towards it I agree with
that let's be co-commissioners I think
we could handle this sure yeah I like
that I'll split the paycheck okay
how much does a commissioner make oh
it's way up there is it 60 it's a lot
yeah bowling how much the commissioner
make uh closest to the hole what do you
think the commissioner is going to make
this year I'll say 65
and I'm going to go 72. oh I I have 54
last year oh but okay poor guy well did
he have a good year this year I don't
know
I'd like to be baseball commissioner Dan
just for like a couple of weeks I'd like
to just sit with Rob Bob Rob Manford
yeah but we'll see what's going to do
for two weeks I wouldn't have to have
any power I was just like you know oh
you just want the title yeah just the
title walk around commissioner stay yeah
walk around from you know spring
training complex to spring training sit
where I want to sit okay that'd be kind
of cool yeah you and Peter King you and
Peter King I could see yeah you know
spring training baseball is the best
thing ever invented by mankind yes it is
yes yes it is I've spent many many a
spring in the bleachers here yeah
absolutely wonderful to come here to
this stadium and watch a game you go
down to the Marriott Suites down there
you walk over here you have sure yeah
the beer so a couple of beers absolutely
it's nice he's Sal palantonio covering
his 30th Super Bowl you can catch him on
NFL matchup show with Greg Cosell Darius
Butler on Super Bowl Sunday 9 A.M
Eastern on ESPN2 Sao pal great to see
you buddy thank you for stopping by DP
you're the best we'll take a break we're
back after this